buonasera
vi garantisco che era stivato
scusatemi questa sera mi piacerebbe
portarvi in un viaggio abbastanza
inconsueto un viaggio esattamente a metà
strada tra l'arte e la scienza qualche
cosa che si muove al di là dei confini
del nostro pianeta terra che esplora i
limiti delle nostre percezioni e che ha
come protagonisti satellite naturale
cioè la luna e delle opere talmente
piccole da essere invisibili e di
conseguenza opere che portano al limite
del concetto stesso di arte visiva
immagino cominciamo dal basso della
terra che ciascuno di voi sia stato
almeno una volta nella vita a visitare
un museo
solitamente si tratta di spazi ampi
pieni di oggetti che potete vedere con i
vostri occhi
tipicamente quadri statue installazioni
di ogni genere esistono musei di ogni
qualità militari musei agricoltura musei
di scienza musei di archeologia e chi
più ne ha più ne metta
e sono distribuiti quasi in ogni dove a
qualcuno è venuto in mente di aprire un
museo in un luogo dove non esiste un
luogo che è stato esplorato quasi 50
anni fa da numerosi equipaggi di una
sola nazione e si chiama luna quali sono
diciamo così i contorni di questa idea
tutto parte da un consorzio statunitense
per la precisione della carolina del sud
questo consorzio che si chiama last
robotics decide di aderire a un progetto
internazionale che è un premio
sostanzialmente iniziato da google il
gigante di mountain view questa
competizione assegna come primo premio
30 milioni di dollari al primo consorzio
privato che posizionerà un oggetto sulla
luna un robot capace di compiere un
percorso di almeno 500 metri e di
mandare a terra una trasmissione di
video in alta risoluzione e l'obiettivo
di questa competizione è quello di
sviluppare
una nuova imprenditoria privata per
potere aprire un'era di sviluppo e di
sfruttamento delle risorse umane e
sostanzialmente le caratteristiche di un
museo che possa essere trasportato da un
oggetto come un'astronave e collocato
sulla luna quali devono essere
sicuramente quantomeno deve essere
leggero perché le stime dei costi per
depositare un chilo in materia sulla
luna
parlano di 1,2 milioni di dollari quindi
sono cifre astronomiche qua da questi
schizzi vedete che il museo assomiglia
un po una lattina
quindi ha un volume inferiore a una
lattina di bibita da 300 ml ed è pensato
e realizzato con materiali che
dovrebbero essere in grado di resistere
per migliaia di anni nelle condizioni
dell'habitat lunare da questo rendering
3d che uno spaccato del museo che si
chiama monarch vedete è una struttura
molto complessa
senza scendere troppo nei dettagli vi
basti sapere che ci sono all'interno
numerose opere d'arte miniaturizzate e
in campionario di materiali e oggetti
che provengono dalla terra e che
simbolicamente rappresentano la società
contemporanea e lennon opere che noi
abbiamo realizzato sono protette da due
di queste dieci viti che vedete
collocate sui dischi superiori inferiori
del cilindro centrale questo invece è il
lander cioè l'oggetto che deposita il
monarchs sulla luna è sostanzialmente
simile alla lunar excursion module che
in italiano chiamiamo lem che si
depositò sulla luna con emissioni del 69
e poi in avanti apollo è fatto di
alluminio è un oggetto che a 4 metri e
mezzo di diametro e capace di depositare
sul suolo lunare 270 chili di materia
utile quindi esperimenti scientifici
oggetti e pensate che brucia ben 1700 kg
di propellente per rallentare la caduta
e fare un soft landing come si dice
questo invece il robottino cioè il rover
quindi un oggetto che ha la capacità di
muoversi alla velocità di 18 centimetri
al secondo massima è alimentato da dai
pannelli fotovoltaici che generano
potenza elettrica massima di 100 watt e
ha poi uno stereo camera per prendere
diciamo delle immagini stereoscopiche in
alta risoluzione
ma come è nata l'idea della nano arte
questa è nata nel 2005 a quei tempi un
artista torinese che si chiama
alessandro scali ci venne a trovare al
dipartimento di fisica del politecnico
di torino e ci mostrò degli schizzi su
un taccuino e ci chiese potete
realizzare queste opere in maniera tale
che non siano visibili all'occhio umano
è lì per lì ci sembra una sfida assurda
ovviamente la risposta era sì si può
fare noi iniziamo questo percorso
insieme a lui e realizzando diverse
opere ed allora siamo sempre andati
braccio braccio ad affrontare diverse
sfide e abbiamo anche raccolto questa
per poter realizzare delle opere da
quello che adesso la luna le specifiche
che ci sono state fornite erano molto
stringenti avevamo necessità di farle su
supporti grandi massimo mm x 1
e qui vedete il supporto di silicio che
a queste dimensioni sopra quel pezzo di
silicio sono state fatte delle incisioni
nanometriche che sono proprio le opere
d'arte equa vedete la mano dell'artista
alessandro scali che regge un porta
campioni con dentro dei minuscoli pezzi
di silicio che sono quelli su cui
abbiamo fatto i campioni e questa è la
bozza della prima opera quindi il
disegno che fa l'artista che si chiama
cam un che è un gioco di parole camon e
moon ed è un impronta che simboleggia
diciamo l'accesso dell'arte terrestre
umana sulla luna e che richiama anche
ovviamente le famosissime orme degli
astronauti che vendeva calcate sul suolo
lunare dalle missioni apollo e
ovviamente una bozza la prima
realizzazione che è stata fatta e questa
che è una litografia che cosa significa
fare una litografia significa trasferire
digitalmente una geometria su un
supporto rigido in questo caso silicio
usando qualcosa tipo un martello uno
scalpello solo che la punta dello
scalpello è veramente piccolissima nel
nostro caso 76 ico metri cioè stiamo
parlando di 76 miliardesimi di mm ed è
fatta non di acciaio come uno scalpello
ma di ioni gallio
che sono il materiale che utilizziamo
per scalare un altra informazione
interessante data da questa barra bianca
qua che è l'indicazione della dimensione
dell'immagine questa barra è un micron
quindi un millesimo di millimetro
questo significa che lor ma che abbiamo
fatto è micrometrica non nanometrica
quindi bisognava impiccio lear la
un'altra considerazione interessante che
cosa stiamo vedendo in realtà questo
signore la cciaa l'intervento di questa
mattina dell'altro alessandro questa
scala di grigi di chiaroscuri che noi
vediamo non ha niente a che fare con ciò
che vediamo con la luce con i nostri
occhi perché questa è un'immagine fatta
con un microscopio elettronico e noi
vediamo le proprietà della materia da
tichy dagli elettroni secondari così si
chiamano che sono immessi in risposta a
un pennello elettronico cioè un fascio
di elettroni primari che va a
scandagliare la superficie dovevamo fare
la più piccola e così l'abbiamo fatta
se guardate la scala dimensionale questa
è adesso 100 nanometri
e questo che è sicuro è un solco voi
vedete questo solco è meno di 50
nanometri di larghezza
il che significa poche decine di atomi
messi uno in fila all'altro è veramente
piccolo però se avete notato
l'opera è molto più semplificata di
quella che avete visto prima
perché è qua ci scontriamo con le
stranezze del mondo quantistico cioè il
principio di indeterminazione di
heisenberg che dice che è
sostanzialmente se io voglio controllare
la forza che esercito col martello sullo
scalpello con una precisione alta
piccolo inciso perché se esercita una
forza troppo alta spa col silicio si
esercita una forza troppo bassa non lo
scalfiscono e quindi non faccio nessuna
incisione per cui ho bisogno di
controllare la forza perdo il controllo
sulla posizione della punta dello
scalpello quindi non so più dove sto
scavando e ottengo un immagine che è un
po sfocata allora devo semplificare
l'immagine perché altrimenti non ho più
la possibilità di renderla nitida e
quindi leggibile e visibile
ovviamente non colloquio ma con il
microscopio elettronico questa è la
seconda opera che è stata realizzata di
nuovo la bozza dell'artista
e fa parte di una serie che l'artista
chiamato social etico cioè ha coniato
questo neologismo per descrivere la
società contemporanea che è
caratterizzata da un elevatissimo
contenuto di tecnologia ma da una
regressione a livello sociale dei
rapporti noi lo abbiamo fatto poi come
coppia micrometrica mantenendo la stessa
geometria il materiale con cui è stato
fatto si dice ma perché si dice perché è
fondamentalmente il materiale ubiquo più
utilizzato più economico più conosciuto
per tutto quello che riguarda i
dispositivi elettronici gli smartphone i
computer qualsiasi cosa abbia
dell'elettronica dentro è basata sul
silicio e noi lo conosciamo bene e
usiamo questo preferibilmente equa
vedete l'opera definitiva semplificata
come prima rispetto alla precedente e
nanometrica come dimensioni vedete la
scala 200 nanometri
questo è lo strumento molto complicato
che è stato utilizzato per realizzare le
opere che è un microscopio elettronico
quindi un pennello elettronico che ci
consente di vedere quello che facciamo è
un fascio jonico che è lo scalpello che
ci consente di scavare la superficie del
silicio
il tutto poi è circondato da una gabbia
di faraday ovvero da una specie di
ragnatela di fili di rame che ci serve
per pulire il l'ambiente di lavoro dal
rumore elettromagnetico che avrà mai
nelle nostre città e ubiquo in
particolare questo strumento è stato
collocato all'interno di un seminterrato
di una palazzina storica insospettabile
della crocetta di torino dove ci sono i
lavori i laboratori del centre for
sustainable food technologists dove
lavoro dell'istituto italiano di
tecnologia quindi lo abbiamo fatto a
torino
questa è la mia collega cascia
lei è l'esperta di litografie e la
persona che ha fatto le incisioni
materialmente sul sito e qua si vede
mentre sta aprendo il portellone della
nostra immaginaria navicella che poi
essere lo strumento con la quale abbiamo
inciso in silicio equa sugli schermi
vedete le due opere d'arte che sono
state realizzate
el impronta dell'artista alessandro
scali quasi a volere calcare la luna
simbolicamente e con questo concluso io
ovviamente voglio ringraziare prima di
tutto
alessandro scali che purtroppo non è
stato presente quando ne potuto venire
ma è lui diciamo l'ideatore dal punto di
vista artistico del progetto cascia che
la persona che si occupata di fare le
incisioni denis e simone che sono
colleghi che hanno tagliato silicio il
professor tiri che è stato il
coordinatore del centro dove abbiamo
provato il team it dix per la sua
eccellente organizzazione dell'evento e
voi per l'attenzione grazie minuti
[Applauso]
[Musica]